I'm I'm in shock  this is insane  I want to start big  the thing that I love about movie making  is how many people it takes to make it  share it a shared accomplishment I have  got to thank the members of the academy  for including me in this group of super  talents I wouldn't be up here without  you  thank you to the women this year  you were so magnificent and so inspiring  this moment  so much bigger  than me  because this door tonight has been  opened  you've sacrificed so much for me to be  able to make my dreams come true  those of you who have ever felt  Injustice because of who you are I stand  here in front of the world with you and  for you I've been a scoundrel in my life  but so many of you in this room have  given me a second chance  and I think that's when we're at our  best when we guide each other towards  Redemption  that is the best of humanity  [Applause]  [Music]